[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's bring in Louis Riddick
the ESPN NFL analyst as uh NFL live from
the combine three to five eastern Rashad
Bateman did uh speak out and had some uh
some words for his GM there uh Lewis
joins us now what what is going on here
in Baltimore Louis hey man I wish I knew
right there Rashad did not really like
that Diddy now that since deleted
I don't know if it was Instagram or
Twitter I guess from my understanding
they all talked and some of it was taken
out of context as they always say in
these kind of situations when someone
gets pretty offended that you didn't
really understand the entire you know
context of the comment etc etc but look
man
I think Rashad kind of let the cat out
of the bag a little bit about some of
maybe the frustrations that some of the
guys internally have there and it
doesn't just really stop
with
how maybe the wide receivers are
utilized you heard him make reference to
or rather you read him make reference to
you know about keeping us healthy about
maybe there being some issues with the
number of injuries that they have every
single year and why it takes it seems
like a protracted amount of time for
guys to come back there's a lot of
things that seem to need to be addressed
internally there the least of which is
Eric DeCosta making a comment about how
you happen to hit on a on a star wide
receiver well well I think um
Hollywood Brown would probably have
something to say about that although you
know we can sit here and debate how good
Hollywood Brown was
and Rashad Bateman when he is healthy
is as good as any receiver in the NFL
the kid has ultimate upside and then
there's a bigger picture too Dan you
know as far as why did they make the
change at the offensive coordinator
position did they feel as though this
offense wasn't evolving enough and
really you know of the modern day
passing game elk that they really want
to be and was Greg Roman not capable of
doing that and can Todd Monk and do that
now for them there's a lot going on
there
that maybe they ought to kind of like
Circle back keep it in-house and kind of
address some things from the ground up
but this leads me to what happens next
week with Lamar Jackson's contract what
do you what do you think they do with
his contract because it it feels like
there's you know
I think he uh said to Stephen A or his
camp or his leaked to Stephen A Smith he
didn't want he wasn't looking for that
guaranteed contract I was told you know
to the contrary he wants to Sean
Watson's contract there
yeah look and you know I have been
steadfast in my belief that he should
not and no one else should not should
treat desean's contract as an anomaly
okay it is what it is it's there it's
not the Mars Jackson's fault yeah it's
not his responsibility to try and
interpret or make excuses for Jimmy
Haslam in the Browns management as far
as how they structure that it's not his
responsibility number one so if he is
asking for 230 plus fully guaranteed at
signing great go for it absolutely go
for it now from there what actually was
offered and what actually is he being
offered or rather what is he actually
asking for
I don't it's anybody's guess right now
because this is a unique situation as
you know and he's negotiating on his own
behalf with some help from outside uh
forces I guess why wouldn't he ask for
Deshawn Watson's contract I mean I I get
it pay him but I would ask for it
absolutely I agree I agree and I and I
think look my gut
well geez my gut tells me that this is
going to really be one of those things
that becomes protracted and ultimately
ends with him not being there that's
what I think is going to ultimately
happen because they're just not going to
pay him what he wants and I think we all
know that if he hit the open market and
or was available via a sign and trade
or something or some uh version of that
there would be a team
that would probably top 200 million
fully guaranteed at signing there would
be a team that would do that for him and
it may not be Baltimore and that's fine
and you know what I also know this
having been through this number you know
numerous different times the team that
ultimately you know winds up drafting
you first and has the most Intel most
information about you knows a hell of a
lot more about really probably what your
fair value is in a team coming in from
the outside
and a lot of times what that results in
is you overpaying and kind of like
extending the market past places where
it really should be extended and a lot
of times that can burn you but that does
not mean that I don't think a team will
offer him a contract that will have
Baltimore's Jaws hitting the floor if
they are to make him available which I
think ultimately that's where it's
heading
talking to Louis Riddick of the
mothership the NFL Live Crew today from
three to five eastern uh the combine and
leading up to the draft I was wondering
about this with Bryce young you know if
you're the Bears and you have a higher
grade on him than you do Justin Fields
but but I'm wondering who would be
interested in Justin Fields sometimes we
look at these possible trades or moves
only through the lens of one team but I
don't know if I like Carolina does
Carolina look at him and go that's our
quarterback or Atlanta or any of these
teams you know maybe there's not a
market out there for Justin Fields
therefore that's why they're going to
keep him uh and then maybe trade that
pick down what do you how would you read
this situation yeah I I would I say I
see what you're saying but I'd have a
hard time believing that there wouldn't
be a team in that top ten that wouldn't
say you know what we are willing to go
ahead and set the foundation around him
up front
on the perimeter and then
philosophically philosophically and
conceptually in terms of the right kind
of Coach rightcon offense coordinator
right kind of quarterback coach and it's
funny one of the teams that you
mentioned I was we were just talking
about this on the set yesterday
that being Carolina Panthers all right
from a structural standpoint right now
in the top 10 of those teams that are
there's there's some there's some good
quality coaching staffs Arthur Smith is
someone who I respect tremendously Pete
Carroll you know in Shane Waldron what
they're doing out there in Seattle what
they did with Gino someone I respect you
know tremendously and all but I'll tell
you this Carolina with the combination
of Frank Reich
and now they have Josh McCown and if
Thomas Brown his offensive coordinator
comes over from the Rams
I would I would take that situation for
a Young quarterback like Justin fields
over just about any of them right now
and I I would have a hard time believing
that if they were if they could get
their hands on a young man like that
given what he has been through through
the first two years in terms of regime
change and lack of support
I would have a hard time believing that
Jeff Tepper would not say yeah we'll
take him and we'll build around him if
we can't get a guy if we can't get
somewhere you know out of this nine spot
and move up to a position where we could
get our franchise guy we'll take a guy
like that for sure he he's just got too
much promise then he really does and
we're not we're not giving him a fair
Shake I don't I don't quite honestly I
don't even know how this got so much
steam behind it this whole concept of
the Bears should trade Justin fields and
just drop rice yeah but you reset your
your quarterback contract I I don't
think that's necessary but Justin Fields
after next season now I gotta pay him 50
million dollars a year
well I don't I don't know if that's
necessarily the case that you have to
pay him that okay I understand I
understand resetting the clock in this
in this fascination with people
believing or people feeling as though
you have a better chance at succeeding
if you have a quarterback on a rookie
contract because it frees up all the
salary caps but if he's got a better
grade though Lewis if you think he's
better than Justin fields which most
draft experts do Come Away with a better
grade for Bryce young than they do
Justin fields
well I I'm just I'm I'm not I'm not in
that well I'll tell you this I do love
Bryce young don't get me wrong okay he
is he is a fantastic fantastic would you
take him
over Justin fields
as you're starting given what I could
get in return for moving out of the one
spot to somewhere in the top ten and
relative to what I saw him do unless
there's something out there about Justin
fields that I don't know about
no I wouldn't make that move
I would trade down okay and I would
build out the rest of this offensive
line wide receiver group get some pass
rushers and more corners for for Chicago
and I think we would be rolling
we've shied away from drafting running
backs except for saquon Barkley up high
now you got Bichon Robinson who has a
pretty high grade but you know now the
Cowboys have said you know with
Pollard's injury maybe Zeke is out the
door Mike McCarthy said he wants to run
the football more yeah they ran the ball
a lot weren't they a top five running
team this this is I think Mike
McCarthy's saying I got a guy we're
spending 45 million dollars on and I
don't want him having the ball throwing
the ball as much as these other
quarterbacks do that's what I took away
from this yeah and you know what and it
there's there's a lot to digest from
those comments because
I think the debate becomes especially
when you're talking about the running
game it's volume versus efficiency right
so does he say he wants more volume or
he wants better efficiency because if
he's saying he wants better efficiency
great every every every head coach in OC
does
they weren't efficient one because Tony
needed to get more touches Zeke is done
the offensive line isn't as dominant as
it was and I can understand where they
might feel as though they want to be
more efficient slash run the ball more
because
look they need to do and I've said this
numerous times they need to do a deep
dive on what happened with that last
year like what was where was The Gap as
far as
decision making under Center you take
the snap you're reading out the defense
you're deciding where to go with the
football you're putting the football
where it needs to be put in all the
critical situations you need to do it
because it just wasn't happening
consistently and you ain't gonna tell me
it's just Kellen Moore
there's more to it than that yeah so
there there's a lot of things to unpack
for Dallas man like there always is and
that's why this offseason will they will
give us plenty to talk about the uh
situation with the Jets if if it's true
that the Saints are ready to make an
offer for Derek Carr and it feels like
you know maybe there's a marriage that's
uh you know waiting to happen here the
jets are in a holding pattern
waiting for Aaron Rodgers yeah what do
you think of that strategy
oh man you know
I I've tried to I've talked about this a
couple different times and I and every
time I come away like saying well did I
really represent how I really feel about
this stuff I'm someone who really does
believe in people like taking care of
themselves right and you know from a
physical mental standpoint and sometimes
people go
and you know and do this in ways that
no no maybe we don't agree with or we
just can't see the the method the
methodology to their Madness we know I I
don't know look Aaron does some things
that obviously play themselves out in
the public eye that that invite a lot of
skepticism and people going man come on
I mean enough I'm tired of this this is
exhausting Etc so I don't I don't want
to I don't want to downplay whatever
he's trying to get done personally
but from a pure football team building
standpoint
it's exhausting man
it's exhausting and for the Jets to sit
and go well you know what we're just
going to push all of our chips into the
middle of the table and say look we'll
just wait for Aaron Rodgers
you know because now Nathaniel hackett's
there and they feel like maybe they can
just kind of put this band back together
and he can lift this team to new heights
I I hate the whole Fantasy Football Team
Building Concept like Aaron comes there
and automatically he's great for Garrett
Wilson you know he's great for Corey
Davis he's great for for you know this
entire offense and the next thing you
know we're challenging in the East I
don't believe that to necessarily be the
case especially if he's going to conduct
himself in off season the way he did
last year
so you don't want to be around are you
going to help them out are you going to
teach these guys yeah
you know
last year we we said oh it won't matter
he's he's Aaron Rodgers he'll get on the
same page quickly when he gets to Camp
everyone needs to relax stop sweating
the guy well you saw what happened
but then when we talked to the Kansas
City Chiefs uh before the week 18
doubleheader
and Andy Reid looked and I go Andy
how did how did you change everybody out
in your wide receiver room except one
guy Nicole Hartman you changed everybody
you changed the running back you changed
everything how are you able to how's
Patrick able to take it to the next
another level yeah he goes I'll tell you
how
because as soon as he knew all these
changes were coming and Tyrique left he
got everybody together and said
we're going to work on this all off
season
but then we're going well Aaron doesn't
need what the hell what do you mean
Aaron doesn't need to do that so that
that's what bothers me about this
situation for the Jets
if he's going to come there and spend
his time in off season Dan
who knows what they can do because it is
a talented team we know that but when is
he when has he been willing to do that
recently you don't know Paulie do you
have uh Louis Riddick's combine numbers
I think these are unconfirmed hey don't
don't put those out there man
there's some good stuff it really wasn't
actually it wasn't a good but so you're
an overachiever I got you just under six
two two sixteen yeah hand size 9.63
yeah do you guys want to play Guess the
40-yard dash time man I ran a four seven
wait you're not you don't you know how
the game works Louis we guess and then
you tell it
Stan even Lewis is wrong he ran a four
seven two
let me just tell you man
it was not a good morning
well I'll tell you what I tell the story
all the time this is an old RCA Dome no
one was here I mean it was just like it
was like so like just you know watered
down and nothing like it is now yeah and
I get up to the line
and first of all you know
the lines that were set up for where you
put your hands and your feet were not
exactly they didn't have like 40 camps
and all that crap that they have now for
these guys to get prepared so I'm like
oh well this is not this is gonna mess
me so I was I'm all messed up as far as
my hands my feet and where I want to
start and I look up to my right and in
the stands I literally I see Mr Al Davis
sitting there like this okay it's got
his glasses pulled down yeah and then
it's him it's Bill Parcells and Gil
Brandt and they're looking at me like
will you just run already and I'm just
like holy
I think Rich Eisen did better than that
yeah I you know I ran faster at my pro
day yeah
but that that combine thing haunts me
man no Kuiper won't let me forget it
they won't let me forget it did you ever
hear this story about orlowsky and the
40-yard dash in high school
where there's a Randy and soul from
Connecticut was coming over to scout him
and and orlovsky moved the cone he ran
his 40-yard dash and he ran 37 yards but
Randy Edsel the Yukon coach thought that
that was his time for a 40. it was
actually his time for a 37-yard dash
what was the time and he uh it was
respectable I think for
um I think it shocked everybody and
that's the one scholarship offer
orlovsky got but he actually manipulated
his 40-yard dash time
I did not know that but I am glad I know
that I gotta respect that though
hey you do what you got to do now yeah I
wish I wish I could have done that
somehow out the combine if you would run
a 37-yard dash I would have ran like a
four four four
oh yeah yeah
speed's overrated and it's about being
quick
you know what that's why at some point
in time then you know they're going to
do away with the 40 and it'll all be GPS
tracking numbers which is more accurate
anyway what do you mean a lot of
scouting departments have already
transitioned to that they don't I mean
they they do they track the 40 and they
record it and they want the verified
numbers but they really don't use that
as a way to really determine the
player's functional speed which is smart
great to talk to you have fun out there
in Indy and thanks for joining us of
course man thank you it's Louis Riddick
he ran a four seven two oh wait a minute
not supposed to bring that up anymore
NFL live from three to five eastern
Today part of the combine coverage there